مكافاه بعشره ملايين دولار رصدتها واشنطن
لا اعتقال هذا الرجل فمن هو ولماذا تلاحقه
امريكا القرصان الروسي ميخائيل متهم
باختراق اهداف في الولايات المتحده من
داخل روسيا باستخدام برنامج فديه
الكترونيه للحصول من ضحاياه على مبالغه
تصل قيمتها الاجماليه الى 200 مليون دولار
العدل الامريكي تقول ان ميخائيل يقوم
بتجفير بيانات العديد من الضحايا ومنهم
ضباط شرطه ومستشفياته ومدارس الى جانب
معلومات حساسه حول عصابات ومجرمين كما
ذكرت الوزاره ان ميخائيل اعلن مسؤوليته عن
نشر بيانات الشرطه المسروقه على الانترنت
مثل عناوين منازل الضباط وبياناتهم
الماليه في مكان رده بانه لا يبالي لان
احتمالاتي مثوله امام محكمه امريكيه ضئيله
لعدم وجود اتفاقيه لتسليم المجرمين بين
واشنطن وموسكو
[موسيقى]